what's going on there reject nation lauren
francesca who hasn't been on this channel
in a few years is now back with me today yes
she's back in l.a yes follow her on social
media yes actress influencer model director
producer writer dancer uh philanthropist just
follow me real estate mogul dog lover dog
lover you're a follow we are gonna watch today
the movie encanto that's right guys not marvel
dc or star wars john is uh getting surgery
right now that tooth thing that you guys were
making fun of him about well he's getting
that fix he's going to be out of commission
for a few days so i was like time to catch
up on some movies she's been wanting to hang
out and i said no no no we don't hang out
we collab and now we're gonna watch sewer
together full length watch along where you
sync up with the time girlfriend contour we'll
be at our patreon page cover a whole bunch
of things over there as well thank you all
who have joined but if you're not gonna follow
us on patreon the least you can do is leave
a like that would be very much appreciated
and then boys at prepper thank you so much
for helping us edit down these highlights
let's get to it i hear this movie is a joy
this candle holds the miracle given to our
family your abuelo pedro and i were forced
to flee our home oh we could not escape the
dangers and your abuelo
thank god i need blessed with a refuge in
which to live
oh that's what an encounter is the miracle
blessed each with a magic gift to help us
and together our family's gifts have made
our new home a paradise wow real estate
whatever gift awaits will be just as special
as you
cool
the truth is
oh my gosh she doesn't have a gift oh no
you're deflecting they were just asking about
the family
oh that is so sad that's so sad i gave you
the special since you're the only mother god
kid with no gift i call it the nut special
special since uh you have no gift
if i was you i'll be really sad
i am just as special as the rest of my family
all right guys where do i drop the wagon maybe
your gift is being in denial yeah damn all
my hispanic friends have been holding out
on me look what they all do that's what this
movie's telling me thank you oh it's nothing
a little sisterly advice if you weren't always
trying too hard you wouldn't be in the way
it's called helping and i'm not in the way
you are she reminds me so much of you lauren
thanks greg thank you remember remember you
have nothing nothing to prove oh that's a
good message the best way for some of us to
help is to step aside let the rest of the
family do what they do best this is really
sad oh if the gift ceremony doesn't go well
this time tonight will be hard for us i don't
know what it's like to not be gifted how do
i identify with this character
how do we how do we invest in this place
[ __ ] the pressure
you could put on here in this family
oh no why oh god
hey i understand you
of course they can come what he talks that
is the coolest power ever oh man wow what
whoa oh you lucky little kid
like doctor who we need a picture everyone
come come come come please don't ask her to
take it oh my god let her be in the picture
she's not in the picture on the picture why
isn't she in the picture i am totally fine
i will stand on the side as you shine
i can't hear what's broken can't control the
morning rain or a hurricane
am i too late for a miracle no no you have
nothing to prove i'm glad we could meet up
lauren so we could just cry together holy
[ __ ] did you pick this one on purpose and
we don't have tissues i am so sorry
oh no
when she gets cut why is this movie so meaner
oh
no she's breaking everything this is a breaking
act too right now
what is going on the tiles were falling and
there were cracks everywhere and the candle
almost went out oh show me
what oh she had a vision there is nothing
wrong with la casa madrigal the magic is strong
and so are the drinks
oh well who's in denial now oh
what are you doing knowing how this movie
treats her she's gonna fall down and break
her neck i need you
cracks in our casita she believes her oh she
believed her yeah take the candle i will save
the miracle oh no wait how do i save a mirror
i was like what is she doing dolores says
you're totally freaking out any chance you
maybe know something about last night with
the magic spoken to the guzmans about mariano's
proposal to isabella dolores do we have a
date tonight he wants five babies wow lisa
if you know what's hurting the magic and it
gets worse because you won't tell me what's
wrong nothing's wrong wow sorry that uh that
snuck out there what i meant was am i finally
platinum i take what i'm handed i'll break
what's demanded but
miranda write this sounds like a song this
is awesome
no mistakes
amazing yeah i won't run to write that it
sounds like a lin-manuel song that's good
last night when you saw the cracks i felt
weak oh the magic is with the ring i got chills
start with bruno's tower find that vision
that place is off limits for a reason uh-oh
the one non-magic person has to save the magic
people
your future awaits oh wow welcome to the family
my [ __ ]
oh no no
oh my goodness she is brave
hurting the oh
oh no she can feel it
is that a bad thing that she's putting the
cracks back together it certainly appears
that way
she's hurting the magic oh no
how did she do that
if he had a vision about someone what would
it mean we don't talk about bruno i know it's
just what a nightmare what if you didn't understand
what he saw then you better figure it out
because it was coming for you we don't talk
about why
no no
oh that's the worst
oh no i broke into bruno's tower i found his
last vision the family's in trouble the magic
is dying the house is breaking we skipped
his waiting and i think it's all because of
me no boy no the house is not breaking louise's
gift is not fading no one will know just act
normal no one has to know listening girl uh-oh
no stop the gossiping
that's what a [ __ ] so fast
man those rats know a lot huh they're fast
they know something they know something
that was nuts
oh boy it was like a horror experience for
you oh oh my goodness little girl whoa
oh boy
you're very sweaty
oh no
that's good that's good wait have you been
in here patching the cracks all the patching
is done by hernando who is it i'm hernando
and i'm scared of nothing it's actually me
i say my real gift was acting i look like
him i declare this definitely
oh wow that's so sad i had this vision the
night that you didn't get your gift and i
saw the magic in danger i saw you maybe she's
the savior you wrecked my vision cave which
is a problem because i need a big open space
we'll find one where this is my room oh what
what if i show you something worse if i see
something that you don't like you're gonna
be all bruno makes bad things happen oh he's
creepy and his vision killed my goldfish
it's the candle the candle's getting brighter
i
i think you're gonna help the candle how others
there's someone with you and you get a fighter
wait no no no no is that a hug oh to make
the candle bright you have to embrace her
embrace who oh almost there almost there i
got
get out apologize for ruining my life go on
oh my god it's not worth it let the magic
die oh my god the only thing you have ever
done for me nothing is messed up you can still
marry that big dumb hulk i never wanted to
marry him i was doing it for the family oh
wow that is a very serious confession wow
okay get over here bring it in i just made
something unexpected what else can i do wait
bring it in bring it in
i wish i could do that with my sister i know
they hit up jaby kawai right now
yes i don't know why you weren't giving a
gift but it is not an excuse for you to hurt
this family no she doesn't get it i will never
be good enough for you no matter how hard
i try no that's not you don't need to be you're
the one that doesn't care you are the one
breaking our home the miracle is dying because
of you
oh
uh oh no no
just get the kid
god i hope oh freaking bruno's okay damn oh
no
oh
oh no
jesus christ i was given a miracle a second
chance and i was so afraid to lose it that
i lost sight of who our miracle was for
i asked my parent for help
she said to me
hey hey yeah you got to have disney
it was me i was like go and she was like she
only wanted to help i don't care what you
think of me but if you're too stubborn to
to oh i think it's
just your
a gift is you not some gift just you a miracle
is you okay so we're gonna talk about
you take care of your mother when you make
her proud you write your own poetry every
night when you go to sleep and i'm seizing
the moment so would you wake up and notice
me i see you i hear you before the celebration
what
oh wow oh yeah
it's a really beautiful message man yeah that's
a really beautiful message
yes she made the photo
wow miranda i called it yeah
oh yeah yeah it was like the rap rhythm style
i was like this sounds a lot like his flavor
wrap i was more touching than i expected it
to be yeah wasn't the animation it's so great
it's amazing it's so expressive they really
know how to utilize those musical numbers
just tell a wide variety of styles that was
beautiful wow i thought it was like crazy
i was like pretty contained too there's they
all took this one little section but they
managed to do so much with it yeah it was
beautiful i just i didn't know i was going
to cry all night tonight thank you for that
yeah i think you needed it yeah i think you
need it you just cry you deserved it yeah
you earned this cry tonight lord
like 20 minutes in at the very end i was like
this might be my new favorite disney movie
i think so wouldn't blame you for feeling
that way yeah that was beautiful it was amazing
did she get a gift at the end did i super
that's her her gift is her being herself oh
that's so beautiful or she's the sorcerer
supreme she's a witch he's evil it's a warning
time when you told me we're gonna watch like
a two-hour movie i was like oh my god i've
seen the batman three times this is nothing
it's a walk in the park yeah marvel trained
us to see if there's a post-credits scene
for everything we watch now yeah that's what
i'm waiting for yeah we're just thinking all
right guys we're gonna keep it straight to
the point here because it's pretty late at
night but uh obviously laura what do you think
lauren tell the audience what you thought
it was best disney movie ever i laughed i
cried i learned about myself i want to call
myself
this changed my life changed my life i'm quitting
all social media focusing on what's important
right here right my gifts don't matter they
mean nothing maybe nothing no matter i'm good
enough yeah that has a really great message
about you know funny some things we were talking
about beforehand about like self-worth and
i feel like you don't have to prove yourself
and not feeling it's like there's a there's
a weird correlation i think you can make in
life in a lot of ways where you feel like
you're you can be determined at least from
you know still all the hispanic culture but
we're talking like a lot of american culture
especially that a lot of your worth is determined
by your career success but like that's what
it's about what it's about is who you are
as a person like this is really a message
about unconditional love with your family
and such you're gonna make me cry again i
know it's a great message it's a great it's
a great message about feeling like you don't
have to try to prove yourself to to anyone
even your family members that you are valuable
enough as a human being and i think that message
is so powerful and i didn't i kind of saw
him like the theme was stated early on i'm
like you know to prove yourself here about
like i know that thing was stated early on
but i expected to wrap around such a powerful
lesson for everyone involved i thought it
would just be like for her and it i like the
i really like the direction it took because
it seemed like it was gonna be you know oh
she would probably be the one with the craziest
gifts that would be unlocked or something
but it wasn't about that her gift was saving
her la familia or el familia do you speak
spanish no but i think la familia is correct
la familia sounds right yeah sounds right
what was your favorite song uh wow there's
so many i look i really like the one that
uh maybe it was uh julieta when it was uh
it was like the it was the one where you were
like oh linwell miranda probably didn't work
at one yeah yeah there was like dance moments
in it like i just wanted to dance the whole
movie i loved how expressive it was it was
so sweeping like obviously colorful however
it's like the way they i don't even know how
to quite put it into words like they had amazing
camera work here and they did something sometimes
like psychedelic the flowers were just amazing
i loved it it really seemed like hone in on
like latin culture the food the food i am
so hungry dude i am starving yeah i am like
so hungry and it looked really good even though
it was a cartoon i was wanting to taste that
yeah wow i want to go to your house for dinner
and i i just think the way the story weaved
was unexpected like there were just a couple
of predictable things like it's like okay
bruno's has to be around or live somewhere
but yeah i didn't expect them to be just like
right there watching over the family this
whole time i thought it was really cool they
did with the uh with abuela you know um like
what are you're italian right yeah italian
i'm italian filipino so it's all similar it's
all similar it's the same thing yeah it's
the same thing same thing yeah exactly but
uh i mean every my whole life i grew up around
like latin culture even my fiance spanish
you know and so i've been exposed to a lot
of this but i think even in my i think filipino
culture and i think there's some parts of
italian culture too i think even filipino
culture you know you do have that because
there's such a hierarchy with family a lot
of the time and especially when you're close
with your relatives it's like grandma top
of the chain you know and then you can feel
like your whole family is determined by what
your grandma kind of thinks about everything
you know so i like that they have this like
matriarch yeah figured they had this whole
arc with the with the grandma too that i thought
was insane yeah sad yeah when they they within
the first five minutes it was like the the
dad and mm-hmm it's just really sad it was
heartbreaking it was really sounds like this
was mean to our main character let's keep
putting her down but i'm like i've been privy
to that in a lot of parts of the world so
yeah and i think a lot of us know what it's
like to be that family member yeah a lot of
us know it's like to be that whether it be
family or school or like i think there's a
lot that people could just identify with um
with with this mirabelle character you know
and uh and even like i like how they i thought
all the family members had wonderful personalities
like everyone was very distinct yeah and the
even with the sister i thought that was a
nice surprise it's all relatable yeah everything
about it is relatable but even with uh the
sister is isabella yeah right right the the
one who's perfect the one who's perfect yeah
like how i love how that got put together
or you know like that is actually something
that weighs on her yeah that she's perfect
and she doesn't want to be with a guy because
she doesn't want to she doesn't want to have
[ __ ] but she has to be perfect that's standard
it's like celebrities yeah it's like me you
know like everyone just looks at me and goes
perfect and you got everything greg you do
and i'm like i too and life's great and i
really have no pain internally so i can't
identify with anyone in this at all because
i don't understand the opposite of happiness
all this crying you were doing i was like
i guess i should try to cry so i was like
hurting myself physically because that's the
only way i could cry anyway this bit's over
but yeah um yeah and i like how the music
really told moved the story forward every
time or was also like revelatory about the
the characters too and the dancing dancing
dancing was amazing i don't know who choreographed
it but they were like really trendy dances
and i know if i used tik-tok i would imagine
a lot of this song to talk right about now
yeah all those dances look like we should
learn them i bet this movie i i could see
why this movie has been developing quite a
reputation what what related rama was the
daddy that was crazy yeah that what was up
with him keep getting the beast stinks was
that is that did that have a meaning yeah
it's a big part of latin culture i don't know
this is like one of the quirks about her or
something like that i don't know but it seems
like a lot of people involved were of like
the actual race which is always cool to see
honored here and uh you can just feel like
a lot of spirit and love here and i like how
i never felt like the comedy was undercutting
dramatic or serious moments sometimes you
know especially like an animated film you
could feel like they're like we gotta keep
it funny so just throwing some comedy here
but they really let certain scenes breathe
and feel like heavy and and really sad you
know really sad yeah this is really sad i
got scared a couple times you freaked out
one time she knocked down her headphones you
could make for a fun edit here yeah sorry
about that that's really scary damn reaction
laura would not survive you're so scared i
get into it i get like really emotional well
i think that's what's cool is that it's very
uh perilous like you feel the peril yeah very
much so so yeah man i mean i think this was
a beautiful film this was beautiful with a
great heart about it and a great lesson for
kids out there i feel even adults can learn
from this movie yeah i'm going to be learning
from this yeah i'm going to be journaling
curious a whole new rebranding for i want
my lord yeah definitely definitely there's
a lot of lessons to be derived from here yes
uh guys thank you to everyone who encouraged
this um i'm just catching up on movies that
i've been wanting to watch believe it or not
watch a little bit more than marvel dc and
star wars and no one's know i want to watch
one of these thank you lord for being here
i appreciate your authentic authentic honest
emotions go follow her on social media where
do you where is the main place you used to
everywhere just you you can since you're on
youtube already just go to my i want my lauren
channel or find me everywhere i want my lauren
if a social media platform starts up lauren
gets on top of it yeah that's uh it's a real
it's real addiction you don't have to prove
anything anymore lord you're not good enough
my phone broke before i got here so i'm just
i'm feeling like there's some weird message
in the universe right now i don't know that's
why you were so vulnerable then today's reaction
yeah this has a meaning i'm supposed to listen
to be in the present moment what what is happening
right now there's so much stuff going on you
have no idea guys uh thank you so much for
being here and uh you can check us out catch
us on patreon we'll talk to you guys soon
you